this was a long time ago 1999 but it
really does feel like I just retired a
week ago as I was going around the ice
it was just a full day of Celebration
the hockey stories that we were telling
the good times that we had over the
years was really quite emotional as I
look back on it everything about those
three or 4 days and that final day there
wouldn't be one thing i' would ever
change like every kid being in sports
was your parents drive you to the games
and I said my last game I'm going to
drive my dad to the game which I thought
was a nice ending to it and the whole
way there he just kept hitting me on the
leg saying you know you can play one
more year I said Dad I think I'm done